T
TO SEE YOU.
>> ANY TIME, THANKS.
>> Tucker: LAUNCH HUNDREDS OF
HUNDREDS OF HUNDREDS OF CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS AFTER
JANUARY 6TH.
THE LARGEST IN HISTORY, THEY
SAY.
BUT SOMEHOW, THEY DID NOT ARREST
SOMEONE CAUGHT ON TAPE
THREATENING TO MURDER A
REPUBLICAN MEMBER OF CONGRESS,
THERE'S BEEN A BIG DEVELOPMENT
ON THIS FRONT.
KEVIN CORKE HAS IT FOR US
TONIGHT.
KEVIN?
>> ESPECIALLY GIVEN WHAT
HAPPENED, STEVE SCALISE, THREATS
OF THIS NATURE GET ATTENTION AS
WELL THEY SHOULD AND THEY HAVE
ACTED, ALBEIT BELATEDLY, RESTING
JEAN HILLS MET LAST WEEKEND IN
THE L.A. AREA.
THE REST ACTUALLY COMES MUCH
LONGER, IT WAS RETURNED IN MAY
AFTER A FEDERAL GRAND JURY.
BACK ON JANUARY 9TH HE CALLED
THE OFFICE OF FLORIDA
CONGRESSMAN MATT GAETZ AND
THREATENED HIM AND HIS FAMILY.
>> TELL MATT GAETZ TO WATCH HIS
BACK, TELL HIM TO WATCH HIS
CHILDREN, TELL THEM TO WATCH
EVERYONE.
I'M COMING FOR HIM, HE'S GOING
TO [BLEEP] DIE.
HE IS A [BLEEP] DESPICABLE
[BLEEP] TYRANT AND I'M GOING
[BLEEP] KILL HIM.
WATCH HIS BACK.
I'M COMING FOR YOU.
I'M GOING TO PUT A BULLET IN YOU
END UP GOING TO PUT A BULLET IN
ONE OF YOUR [BLEEP] KIDS TOO.
I HATE YOU."
>> INCREDIBLE, WE ARE NOW
HEARING ABOUT AN ARREST.
THAT WAS IN JANUARY.
ABOUT A WEEK AGO, A FLOOR SPEECH
SAYING THAT A MAN WAS TRAVELING
TO D.C. AND THREATENING TO KILL
HIM AND DESPITE THE CAPITOL
POLICE'S RECOMMENDATION
ACCORDING TO MATT GAETZ, THE DOJ
STILL DIDN'T PRESS CHARGES PAIDY
THE WAY, HE'S A LONGTIME MEMBER
OF THE MEDIA, HAVING WORKED AS A
CAMERA OPERATOR FOR ABC, NBC AND
CNN.
DOCTOR?
>> Tucker: MEMBER OF CONGRESS
THREATENED WIT